[Music]
i think everyone here is going to love
this one because it has such a sweet
taste of irony in it
it's delicious we love sweet irony irony
tastes irony and it's uh it's a little
new york based so that's always good
okay i'm in all right new york times
the newspaper oh has a column they
called the hunt and it's all about like
uh rent in new york finding places to
live it's like that's what that column
is like house hunting room hunting
whatever finding deals well the
columnist for that uh section of the
paper is now being evicted and sued for
35 grand in unpaid rent oh what the
how the [ __ ] did it even get to 35 grand
nuts bro well if it's new york and new
york it's probably four months
yeah it could be i don't know five grand
seven grand a month maybe kidding me
dude yeah you could live in a box in new
york and pay [ __ ] seven thousand
dollars a month yeah but even at seven
grand that's still five months and
that's the person that write the arc
about how to find places at great deals
and stuff
that is definitely it sounds like
experts these days experts don't know
[ __ ] all about anything
in fact you should probably not listen
to them
but
we should probably listen to them
that's what i see everywhere what makes
someone an expert
if they're wrong they've googled
something three times
like jim crane
like jim cramer paul krugman
paul krugman who's who's an economist
who's still employed all over the
[ __ ] place who's still revered all
the place he famously said about the
internet it's a fad it's not gonna go
anywhere internet is a fad like
that's like one of his biggest [ __ ]
predictions he's like the internet's a
[ __ ] joke and he's still never gonna
make money on the internet he's still
being nostradamus he bro he still gets
awards he still gets revered everywhere
like paul krugman says paul krugman says
is there anything he's been right on
though
[ __ ] if i know
so the the best part is that this
stories actually has a lot of levels to
it it's pretty interesting so this uh
the woman her name's joyce cohen she's
the writer her and her husband both have
this condition i forgot what it's called
but they have like a high sensitivity to
the noise
so they lived in this house in new york
and there was i thought their condition
was plagiarism
we're both writers we're just happy to
be a plagiarist
family
plagiaris couple they'd probably be
cheaper they um they had construction
going on like near their house so they
couldn't take it so they're like let's
um live in a different location for now
until it's done so they go and they sub
um they sublease
an apartment from this guy for three
thousand a month right
the landlord does not know that the
subletting is going on which is always a
bad thing yeah yeah yeah yeah so they're
subleasing
uh after a few months the landlord finds
out hey these two people have been
subleasing i didn't allow that they got
to go you got to kick them out
uh so the guy who was subleasing it
tells them hey landlord found out you
guys got to go i'm sorry about this they
refused to leave squat time
oh no they refuse to leave and things
get super messy they also stop paying
rent
and they started proposing to the um
the dude the in-between guy who was
subleasing to them they're like okay
we'll leave if you pay us like this much
what
happened
dude that happens all the time squatters
rights really do do this
to people i think their sensitivity to
loud noises is [ __ ] that's what i
think
based on this new information i think
that whole thing is a [ __ ] channel
yeah yep
how about if you look at their faces
all right all right let's go it's super
easy to tell how people are sensitive to
noise what if they're going like this
like oh it's too loud yeah they're like
they have earplugs all the time like
shut up [ __ ] yeah a little bit of
empathy for these guys
they look like squares they look like
they look like the people that are
sensitive to noise though
she looks like she's constantly calling
the police because the neighbors are too
loud but then you can't refuse to leave
and he looks like he got his dick cut
off when he was 12. new york seems like
a hard place to live if you have the
noise
yeah dude go to another city go to
montana or some [ __ ] wyoming has a
really low population
is i bet rent's way cheaper than three
dollars yeah so they also they actually
did say no way we've we have been paying
rent we've just been paying it into an
escrow account what does that even mean
they give them the escrow account that
means that they wanted certain demands
fulfilled in order to give up that rent
money
but you shouldn't really get demands
like that if you were you know you're
subleasing yeah you're suffering you're
not even on the contract yeah why are
they adding to the contract that's not
even signing because i guess they know
that they got the [ __ ] in-between guy
by the balls because he's gonna be
taking the yeah because he's the the
name on the paper and he shouldn't have
been doing it in the first place so he's
kind of just wrong are there any like
squatter rights that makes sense
if you are
no there's one where you have to
maintain a squat the whole [ __ ] time
you're there otherwise you have to get
the [ __ ] out
really that's a that's true you can't
just destroy the place so mostly
japanese people can do it really well
okay because the ones where it's like
they don't pay a single dime but they've
like
dwelled there or whatever for a certain
amount of time even even though they're
not on
the papers
now that's their property i'm like what
the [ __ ] and they got a home how
themselves don't work this is [ __ ]
because obviously that piece of land or
property is owned by someone else just
because they're not there and someone
comes in they get it now that's crazy
yeah it is really weird and plus the the
i guess this might be a cool thing i'm
not really sure that in between guy that
sub leads to them in the first place
when he found out the landlord
discovered it and was going to kick him
out he hired a lawyer and said i'm going
to try to fix this you guys don't have
to pay for the lawyer i'll do it can we
can we play a game yeah what's devil's
advocate yeah how do we defend this
from the squatter's point of view
like in earnest
let me become a new york entitled son of
a [ __ ]
hey no okay no not the italian guys
those are good
uh peter
yeah
no i still can't do it it's hard man
i don't know how to do it like it's so
hard well to be fair i guess if we were
going to play devil's advocate do you
have an angle well it's just the
squatters angle they do have leverage
they're they're the ones that uh have
the middle guy by the balls they
technically didn't do anything because
from their angle the person who chose
the sublease whether it was legal or not
was offering them something and then the
second somebody offers you something and
then all right cool and then they take
it away because of something that's not
you're doing it's it is a little bit of
like a
but it's illegal so that's like me going
like but but they're the ones that broke
the law yeah yeah but it's the doors but
it's like this though it's like this hey
nick can you hold this for me sure cool
the cops come especially though there's
cocaine in here he goes well i didn't
know it was illegal they were just
giving me this possession right it's
like what the f it's like at the end of
the day this thing what's in here is
illegal like the source
but what he's but what he's saying is
that there's a victim here
who didn't know
and there was an aggressor who basically
tricked this person into thinking that
so that makes more sense that's why i
want to do this exercise there but then
they i would say that they need to just
move out and they could settle that
whole thing but just move out
but that's not on a whim right it costs
money to move out it costs resources and
time plus they need to [ __ ] find a
new spot right like so that makes more
sense it does make sense because in so
like let's say in real estate right like
um
you buy an apartment building and if you
want to like upgrade it or whatever uh
you know you have to kind of ask the
people to leave right but then some
people don't want to leave because they
they're like you know my lease isn't up
yet and some people also have the right
depending on what state to just stay and
then you have to pay them out to leave
because for them they're locked into
great rates uh like maybe they're paying
a thousand bucks a month and they just
can't afford moving because if they do
they got to pay three thousand dollars a
month for the same kind of apartment
right so
it's kind of customary to pay people to
leave
yeah
basically you're basically bait you're
helping them move because it costs money
it's like a severance package so now i
think we've presented this conversation
up a little bit so it's not just one way
yeah so the couple's writing case clause
and we'll see you guys in the next video
yeah
i still don't think they have over here
i like what we could play another game
where how would you kill these guys
the difference is that
but but like this game i think um
due to the fact that they're sound
sensitive pieces of shits they're
annoying i want to be mean to them
why didn't they fill their house with
those that those black like uh sponge
things they're like bart has yeah the
phone things like some podcaster people
i guess it could why don't they do that
why don't they walk around with [ __ ]
ear plugs hmm they're always cancelling
plus the
noise canceling headphones i did have a
friend who was leasing a a commercial
space and did not know that he was
leasing it was sublease he thought he
was listening directly to the landlord
didn't know in this case
it's been confirmed they knew so from
the beginning they knew it was a
sublease they knew it wasn't allowed
which means they they should be at least
50 liable yeah you know what i'm saying
because they were just joining the risk
too because what that's um uh what's the
word for that uh
corroborating corroboration
right when you're already familiar with
the situation you know that uh that's
not something that should be done but
you're like um this benefits me though
yeah right right you're already you're
aware
it's split screen cooperative
what about some good old-fashioned
violence like hey you don't want to get
out and then you just like grab their
things and start throwing it out and if
they challenge you you pop them in the
face yeah spotter's rights man you'll
lose that case old-school gangster style
they have good calves you'll never
[ __ ] win
my uh my ex's dad went to jail because
he was in denver he had a rental
property a guy moved in there and then
didn't pay rent was refusing to leave
he went over there and uh kicked his ass
yeah he actually kicked his ass but he
also
put him a knuckle sandwich a very key
detail about how he did it was that he
ended up finding all these like dirty
baby diapers outside of the house
and he forced the guy to eat one like he
put it that's too crazy some [ __ ]
mafia [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i mean pay your rent pay a
rent in denver yeah dude anthony said
it's also just a funny thing to go to
jail first i would would they get you
for
it's like i made i made my subleaser eat
some baby diapers
you're like that's hardcore you make
them sound cooler too one of my tenants
wouldn't pay up so i made them pay
through eating [ __ ] complicated but in
this case it's kind of ironic because
you freaking new york times columnist
about this type of [ __ ] how long does it
take to eat an old baby diaper
probably a while dude
that's gonna take like [ __ ] four
hours or something that's like eating a
[ __ ] styrofoam boxes
you know the crazy thing is like in my
mind i feel like eating this [ __ ] is
easier than eating the diapers organic
you want some crazy i'd be like hey can
i just eat the poop off and then like i
don't have to eat the fabric yeah i will
lick the diaper clean just don't make me
eat the [ __ ] non-biodegradable thing
i eat the poop and then just squeeze the
pee into my mouth because like even
though that type of thing is is on his
permanent record it actually like helps
him out because it makes it more of a
badass he does sales for like oracle and
you tell some other guy that type of
[ __ ] open up him a little bit he's a
nerd yeah wow that's expensive so it
makes him look [ __ ] badass right
you're like dude i'm dope sign me up
this guy's cool as hell yeah wait so he
got out and he's just working for oracle
he was always a highly like successful
like tech rental tech dude rental
properties but then this guy
yeah this guy wouldn't pay trash's house
so he went off on him we gotta make this
couple eat a [ __ ] dookie diaper dude
that's nice we know that a loud one
allowed we know it's gonna be harder to
find a dukey diaper under the biting
administration because of the formula
shortage am i right brother
hey you tell him brother
you